how quickly are you able to achieve what
you want to achieve is it supposed to
take a year because you're choosing to
believe that it's supposed to take a
year how quickly can you onboard someone
a friend of mine launched a new service
category in his business and it blew up
and so he hired 30 people in 14 days
first customer service team so when we
had our Q4 planning we had our customer
service director she was like I feel
comfortable saying that I can bring four
people on every month between now and X
launch date and so then I told that
story about my friend who had just done
this he hired 30 people in 14 days
because he had to a lot of times the
necessity is one of the biggest things
that allows us to break our beliefs
because we have to we have no other
choice